más de 10 balas contra las políticas del
presidente de ucrania volodymyr selenski
y un ileso es sergi zephyr jefe de
asesores del líder ucraniano contra el
que atentaron este miércoles hiriendo al
conductor del coche cuando se
encontraban a las afueras de la capital
kiev selenski desde nueva york donde se
encuentra para la asamblea general de la
onu envió un mensaje busca quien está
detrás de esto no lo sé cuáles son esos
poderes podrían ser internos o externos
saludarme con disparos al coche de mi
amigo es una debilidad pero la respuesta
será fuerte de lenski un conocido actor
en ucrania llegó al poder con la promesa
de recuperar la economía y luchar contra
la corrupción y el crimen de hecho esta
semana está previsto que el parlamento
debata una ley presidencial para reducir
la influencia de los oligarcas en la
sociedad ucraniana es por ello que desde
el entorno del presidente señalan como
responsables del atentado a los enemigos
internos pero en el aire también
sospechas contra rusia desde el kremlin
lo niegan por supuesto esto no tiene
nada que ver con la realidad es más bien
una señal de un estado emocional xxi
excitado ucrania lleva en guerra con
separatistas respaldados por rusia desde
2014 en el pasado fin de semana la
disputada región de donets voto en las
elecciones rusas mientras los
movimientos militares aumentan ucrania
está en plena fase de simulacros con
4000 soldados locales y 2.000
extranjeros con presencia de 12 países
entre ellos eeuu sociedad también ha
hecho ensayos con belarús cerca de las
fronteras de la otan y la unión europea
con la participación de 200.000 soldados